you know you and i couldn't have won
oscars for portraying two more different
people
so true one of us playing a brash and
controversial leader
known for loving whiskey and always
being enshrouded in that trademark
cloud of smoke yes and then of course
you play churchill
and here are the nominees for
performance by an actor in a leading
role
christian bale vice
bradley cooper a star is born
[Applause]
willem dafoe at eternity's gate
rami malek bohemian rhapsody
[Applause]
viggo mortensen greenbrook
and the oscar goes to
romney
this is the first oscar and nomination
for romney mallet
[Music]
oh like oh my god uh
my mom is in here somewhere i
i oh i love you i love you lady
my family thank you for all of this uh
i you know my dad didn't get to see me
do
uh any of this he's not but i think he's
looking down on me right now
so uh this is
this is a monumental moment one i i'm so
appreciative to all of you
to everyone who has had a hand in
getting me here
uh to the academy to people who took a
chance on me
every step of the way graham king
dennis o'sullivan everyone at fox and
new regency thank you guys
so much i may not have been the obvious
choice but i guess it worked out
uh um
thank you queen thank you guys for being
for allowing me to be the tiniest part
of your
phenomenal extraordinary legacy i
am forever in your debt uh
um my crew and my cast
i love you you are my equals you are my
betters
i could have never been here without you
um i think about
i think about what it would have been
like to tell little bubba ramey
that uh one day this uh might happen to
him and i think
his curly haired little mind would be
blown
that kid was uh he was struggling with
his identity trying to figure himself
out
and i think to anyone struggling with
theirs and trying to discover their
voice
listen we made a film about a gay man an
immigrant who lived his life
just unapologetically himself
and the fact that i'm celebrating him
and this story with you tonight is is
proof
that we're longing for for stories like
this
i am the son of immigrants from egypt
i'm a first generation american
and
[Applause]
part of my story is being written
right now and i could not be more
grateful
to each and every one of you and and
everyone who believed in me
for for this moment is something i
will treasure for the rest of my life
lucy boynton uh
you're the heart of this film you are
beyond immensely talented
you have captured my heart thank you so
much